christophe crépin porte parole du
syndicat france police policiers en
colère bonjour christophe crépin comment
est-ce que vous accueillez la sortie de
christophe castaner il l'a dit un pas de
couvre-feu national mais le ministre de
l'intérieur a salué des couvre-feux
locaux comme à nice par exemple
oui c'est une bonne chose puisqu'en fait
il faut individualisé ta région les
mesures qui doivent être prises c'est
très bien mais concernant les
fonctionnaires de la sécurité qu'ils
soient policiers gendarmes ou toute
autre personne qui concourent à la
sécurité sur notre pays il est très
important qu'il soit protégé car ce
virus ne se pas de distinction entre les
policiers les exploits niant des
soignants et la population pour nous qui
sommes encore une fois en première ligne
on demande clairement qu'on ait des
moyens de protection qui sont évidemment
indispensables et qu en plus on n'est
même pas sûr que nous mêmes policiers on
n'est pas vecteur de contaminer d'autres
personnes par les contrôles on doit pas
se mettre à un mec d'une personne
puisque les personnes sur battant gm
haute et en fait elles sont toujours
contre les forces de police
donc il est essentiel qu'on ait des
bases qu'on ait une possibilité de se
protéger aussi bien pour ne pas
contaminer les billets personnes et
aussi pour nous même ne pas être
contaminé
bon je tiens à rendre hommage à ceux
commandés compagnies républicaines de
sécurité qui a exercé le droit de
retraite ces fonctionnaires si on n'a
pas le matériel on peut pas le faire
dans de bonnes conditions et on expose
haussier les citoyens de notre pays à ce
qu'on puisse nous mêmes contaminées vous
parlez donc d'un droit de retrait
possible
est ce que c'est un ultimatum s'il
devait intervenir quand pourquoi épingle
du matin aux médias qu'il était
important que le duplicate police
on doit être porte-parole des policiers
c'est ce que je suis et je dois à mon
ministre de tutelle lui a tiré sur
l'inclusion sur le fait qu'on a besoin
de gros moyens pour travailler dans de
bonnes conditions
il a autour de lui des gens qui viennent
du milieu médical il a k'un de leur
demander est-ce qu'on peut travailler
avec ou sans basse
il ya un appel général qui a été lancée
sur les zones parisien où la grande île
aux fonctionnaires quand on veut les
battre
au jour d'aujourd'hui vous avez dit que
c'était une erreur mais mes collègues
doivent tout
porter un masque de protection quand je
les dis on ne sait pas si nous aimons
néo pas porter ils ont plus on est haut
tellement proches de la population n'est
pas un mec qu'on peut recevoir les
problématiques en plus qu'on comprend
les gens une des documents ces documents
sauf sur papier et donc en fait on
obligé des touchés on connaît pas
exactement le mode provocation savait
qu'il était démis aussi bien pour la
police que pour les aides-soignants que
pour tout le monde c'est la raison pour
laquelle on peut invoquer le droit de
retrait nous sommes des policiers
républicains nous n'oublierons pas je
pense que là j'espère que mon ministre
prendra la mesure de l'événement et qui
donnera à chaque policier la possibilité
de se protéger
justement christophe crépin donc hier
vous est adressée à christophe castaner
je tombe par rapport à ce droit de
retrait il vient de s'exprimer
il y à moins d'une demi heure comment
est-ce que vous accueillez sa réponse
par rapport à voir revendications moi
j'ai pas entendu qu'il allait dire que
je policiers allaient avoir masqué avoir
déroulé protection j'attends nous sommes
des policiers républicains nous sommes
vraiment engagée c'est tous les
politiques qui s'engagent dans la police
c'est pour les idéologistes pour être
auprès du citoyen surtout notre
profession on a vraiment besoin et
auprès des citoyens
là on est dans une dans une guerre comme
l'a écrit le président de la république
il nous faut juste les moyens pour
pouvoir appliquer efficacement contre
pied de guerre christophe castaner a
évoqué tout à l'heure 1 650 1000
contrôles dans les 48 premières heures
est ce que ça va continuer selon vous
tue ce qu'il a exhorté les français à
être plus discipliné il a notamment de
monter au police municipale d'intervenir
comment est-ce que vous accueillez ces
mesures il est bien évident que les gens
qui ont compris la problématique ce jour
là il faut ce qu'on leur demande ils ont
compris que j'étais plus importante les
dvd gens qui s'offre un tout petit peu
rebelle qui pensent que ça a valu l'ire
alors petite activité altipan d'huile
dans les choses comme ça et yves
elle-même et collègues
il ya des endroits où mes collègues se
font si c'est pas progressé parce que
ils veulent continuer à être sur la voie
publique à are au pied les collègues l'a
très peu plus le vrai et que ce seuil la
police municipale la police nationale
sur les gendarmes ils font du grand
respect pour tous les acteurs de la
sécurité
dernière question christophe crépin dans
quel état d'esprit sont les
et forces de l'ordre au niveau mental
j'ai envie de dire au niveau
psychologique est ce que ils vont bien
par rapport à cette crise ce qu'ils vont
pouvoir tenir encore longtemps encore
longtemps je ne saurais vous dire mais
en tout cas une chose est sûr c'est qu'à
chaque fois qu'on a eu des crises
majeures et joue de retraite et j'en
passe là aujourd'hui encore une fois
nous sommes confrontés à une situation
exceptionnelle que moi même
en quarante ans de police n'avait pas
connu et on fera front c'est chiant
parce que le politique entend les
policiers comme canton et soignants
comme quand on est à des besoins de
l'état on s'engage pour une valeur des
vraies valeurs républicaines on fera
face et juste au delà les moyens pour
qu'on puisse se protéger et aussi
coproduit se reposer merci christophe
crépin d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes le porte
parole du syndicat france police
policiers en colère